you ready oh yeah I'm ready
alright y'all ladies gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right yeah welcome back to ripping
with Griffin it's just me today happy
new year 2020 is here we don't do a
starter gear off with a solo episode
because I love y'all
ladies and gentlemen so I just wanted to
recap 2019 to talk about the events
that's been happening this week in a
bunch of stuff but here we go okay I
hope you still like the woo-woos cuz we
still gonna do it up into uh 20 20 22
any whoo so anyways guys I just want to
thank everybody for listening to riffing
with Griffin in 2019
I appreciate the growth I've had a
really great time doing this making the
content like I got my new Malcolm X
glasses on so if you listen in to it you
gonna have to watch YouTube but anyways
I really appreciate everything that has
happened like just the growth and you
know all the messages and all the stuff
I've gotten look I want to thank people
that have contributed to this show so I
want to thank handle the hangover candle
company for the candles are still
burning them they're great I want to
thank I forgot how I wish I had all
these people's names but you know the
people that made the art and all that
stuff that they send I love it you know
I love all my guests you know you know
like I got this from Rick Glassman I
really enjoyed doing Rick Glassman his
podcast take your shoes off so he gave
me this you know mr. Potato Head cup
which is I don't know if it's actually a
good gift but it's actually funny
myspace X hat from Dylan Dylan Dickstein
who's I just heard from him he's about
to join a Mars program exactly what he
said he wanted to do so I think he's
gonna be living out in the desert and
he's gonna be like like in sort of Mars
conditions you know prepare himself so
he's actually doing that my buddy Ben
who I talk about on the podcast love me
she check out his podcast my podcast
would Bend I have this little sticker
right here
he's a trucking along you know he's you
know so help him out by listening to him
but anyways and I also wanna say I
always say I don't have any help I'm
looking for a nerd but you know what
secretly behind the scenes I do have a
nerd I got one nerd that helps me out
all the time he makes my little
Instagram clips and he you know anything
I ask him to do he does and his name is
Dominick Joseph he's actually on
Instagram so shout-out to Dominic for
all the help that he's done and of
course the theme song so I want to thank
dope APOD an octave cat and detective
designs for Eli one winterman and you
know those guys for uh you know all the
the great music that they sent and you
know my main theme song so I want to
thank you for that unless you know let's
make 2020 the best you know I thought
like I am I finished put this down
actually do it like this I thought I
made I finished off a 20-19 pretty
strong you know I had what she call the
Anthony Jeselnik Chris D'Elia and Redman
on the podcast and you know I thought
those does look great finished there so
I got a bunch of great guests lined up
for 2020 but I'm gonna try to do some
more solo episodes to me cuz I love
having guests but I kind of like just
talking [ __ ] just you know just talking
about what I think is going on in the
world and there is some crazy [ __ ] going
on this week I wanted to talk about a
couple things in particular so today's
episode oh by the way - you know and
then please look at my calendar Eric
Griffin calm cuz I got a bunch of twenty
twenty dates coming up if you want to
see me live usually at the front end of
the podcast on youtube I usually have
like a little thing that shows where I'm
gonna be but just for you people that
are just listening hey you know if you
want to see me live go to Eric Griffin
calm and I'm updating my website
constantly so - just to have the dates
of where I'm gonna be in a ticket links
and all that stuff so please check that
out come see me live I love performing
stand-up comedy I love doing this so
come on check it out but today's episode
I just want to talk about a few things a
couple of current events that I want to
talk about and I want to talk about the
streaming wars that's happening right
now the streaming wars you know Netflix
Hulu isn't the Apple TV I want to talk
about that and a couple of reviews in
there within this
shows that I've been watching and on the
finish off with a light Star Wars review
because I think I'm having some you know
one of the I think both the Lee brothers
I got come on are different times and of
course I know we're gonna talk star wars
and stuff like that but you know again
I'm just I'm just I'm out here doing it
so I hope you enjoy but crazy [ __ ] is
going on right now in the world I feel
like like the Pope I think the Pope has
lost his mind
or he just doesn't want to be the Pope
anymore like this dude is out here
slapping people so this woman so he's
sort of Pope's walking by shaking hands
with you know the fans the Catholic fans
or whoever you know I guess the Pope but
you call them fans or followers I don't
know it's like a fence where you can
like actually touch him you know it's
crazy because I remember I went to
Catholic school when I was a kid like
really small and I remember like being
outside at like I like a sort of parade
thing and the Pope drove by real fast in
like a bulletproof thing you know I know
it's like you were like oh man there's
the Pope but now this Pope is just out
here you know kissing babies and shaking
hands with people so he walks by this
woman and she holds his hand grabs him
sort of and pulls him towards her and he
freaks out he's like you know he's mad
not even freaks out the [ __ ]
mad okay you see the video the Pope is
mad he's like you know he slaps her hand
like [ __ ] don't you grab me and then he
like walks away from her like a real
like crotchety old man now um on both
sides of this okay all right let's start
with the woman so this is the Pope like
if you're a Catholic it's like the Pope
and then above the Pope is basically
angels you know Virgin Mary Jesus
whatever you believe in the Pope is
supposed to be the last stop so I
totally get that this is the Pope and
you want to shake his hand and you want
to do more you be like god I mr. Pope it
would be like if you add a Star Wars
convention
you had a Star Wars convention and
George Lucas
it's walking by shaking hands you kind
of want to be like you know I get the
idea of grabbing his hand at being like
yo explain Jar Jar Binks [ __ ] you know
or whatever whatever you would say to
George Lucas but it would be like um
that would be like amazing if you're
like a huge Star Wars follower here's
George Lucas The Godfather of this whole
thing you would want to shake his hand
you would want to do more than just
shake his hand you want you're just in
awe of that moment so I totally get that
you know what I mean you know or Mark
Hamill walks by you know I mean you want
to be like oh my god Luke I am your
father
you were just all the crazy [ __ ] that
you would want to do this is the Pope so
I get this woman was like overzealous
but damn Pope you gotta beat the [ __ ]
down he slapped her hand like it's
coming you know and he's been doing this
a lot actually cuz there's another video
of him taking confessions not no no he
wasn't taking I'm sorry it was like I'm
like after mass type of thing and people
are walking up shaking his hand and so
many people wanted to kiss his hand and
he visibly is like pulling his hand away
like nope nope and then everybody's kind
of like I almost got you almost kissed a
boat which again I totally get if you
believe in what you believe in you think
it's like the end-all be-all
but he's like really not I don't think
he's handling in it handling it very
diplomatically or as like the leader of
the church he's certainly coming across
like man I'm tired of this like he wants
to retire like get me the hell out of
here I mean it's rude if you see the
videos it's really funny I mean I may or
may not have the the videos on here I'm
out I'm not Rick Glassman so I don't do
a lot of edits maybe I should I don't
know but it's hard but they are they
gonna be right there but it's just I
just think like at what point is he
gonna just slap somebody across the face
like don't touch me like enough is
enough you know or my thing is like just
don't have the meet and greets you know
if you don't want to like you don't want
to touch you're the freakin Pope man you
know you you know you laying hands on
people and people feel like they feel
blessed it is it would change their life
if you're a staunch Catholic Christian
and you
a hundred percent invested in what you
think the Pope is and you get to shake
the Pope's hand like damn you don't
understand that that's overwhelming for
people I mean this guy's like forgotten
his position I don't know I mean I don't
know how you feel about it you know I'm
sure you'll tell me in the comments so
please go down in the comments and let
me know what you think about that but I
think the Pope is like on his way out he
might just be like you know what [ __ ]
this I'm out all right that's the Pope
it's gonna the singer might for the Pope
nobody so my other story that I saw that
really like tickle my fancy was
Gabrielle Union the actress married to
Dwyane Wade the basketball star
Gabrielle Union was in a uber the uber
drops her off at her place and the uber
drivers like yo I gotta go to the
bathroom can I go to the bathroom and
then he goes he takes a [ __ ] I don't
know if it was a guy or girl whoever it
is he got a [ __ ] and then she goes on
the internet and [ __ ] shames him you
can't be [ __ ] shaming people look I
can't stand this like people that have
bathroom restrictions that they're like
yo if I say he can I use your bathroom
and they're like yeah but you know just
be like [ __ ] you that there's only two
things you doing there you know well for
the most like 98% is you pee or you [ __ ]
and you're doing them at the same time
and you might if you sick or feminine
stuff whatever's going on in there but
like you I can't do what you're supposed
to do in this room like this is what the
rooms designed for like what else are
you doing in there is this like her
bathroom and arts and crafts is it like
a Chinese food laundromat situation like
that's what you do in the bathroom you
freak his [ __ ] so it's like light a
candle turn on the air and stop like
acting like how it's ridiculous that
people find it outrageous that somebody
used the bathroom look like you tripping
off somebody using the bathroom I think
I think that's shameful right there I
think that really is shameful I mean
I get the other side too nobody wants to
smell somebody else's [ __ ] it's not like
you left the door open you know like if
it did let that be different like if the
story was yo someone this uber driver
comes in takes a [ __ ] leave the bathroom
door open and then walks out I can't
stand that now one time I was at this
long time ago is I just lesbian party it
was a lesbian party because it was a
lesbian couple and they had all their
lesbian friends there and a few of
they're like you know whatever friends I
was one of the friends and I remember
there was this girl who like she I don't
know she was like one of those like I'm
a I'm a she very masculine lesbian chick
and like it was a small place where
there was like a bathroom and then it
opened up and then the living room was
right there I mean this chick straight
up winning there took a [ __ ] and then
stormed out of the bathroom with the
door wide open like nothing like year
like she was like wafting like relishing
and then like it's look how masculine I
am smell that [ __ ] fools at this party
and it was just like oh I never I'll
never forget that I think I think that's
a funny thing that you can remember the
worst shits you smelled of someone else
it's like a very scarring situation
because I remember - but eyebrows
working I was working at this school and
I it was like with like there was this
nun rest her soul cuz she died but she
would go into the fact there was a
bathroom in the hallway of the office I
worked in the office you know and then
she would straight go take a [ __ ] all
the time and just like nothing like the
door would be open it you know and what
do you do when a nun takes a [ __ ] what
do you say you want to be like yo um can
you call the door like it's such a it's
such an awkward like weird situation
when somebody goes to the bathroom and
they don't they don't do their part you
know what I mean like if there's a
candle in there it's clearly you
supposed to like this or there's some
spray clearly spray even though the
spray don't really help but like there's
got to be some [ __ ] etiquette okay
there's got to be [ __ ] etiquettes aside
[ __ ] anacott that when you go into the
bathroom do these things like you don't
storm out the bathroom
you don't mean you kind of like you you
inch out you open the door a little bit
you inch out you close it and then you
make an announcement that's gonna take a
minute you know whatever your thing is
but there's got to be some [ __ ]
etiquette and I think we need to follow
those rules you know well let's make the
rules I think that's the rule rule one
rule if you're not at your place and you
take a [ __ ]
you got a courtesy flush right away
that's rule number one as soon as it
hits the water spoon sploosh flush so
they can cut down on any like you know
lingering odors so let that's the first
thing right there alright let's do that
you know if there's a candle like I said
candle in there light it
spray spray make sure the air is thing
is on when you leave the door when you
leave in you don't open the door super
wide you open it enough that you can
inch out close it quick boom [ __ ]
etiquette rules if you have some other
ones please tell me but I don't want to
talk the whole park ass about [ __ ]
all right let's get to the thing that I
really wanted to talk about and this is
the freaking streaming wars Oh singing
my stream Wars so as you know all of
these new streaming services have
started precedent we tell you my
personal entertainment situation I still
have cable I still get spectrum cable
because I like live sports and all that
and I know there's ways to watch the
other ways but I just I like having the
cable I like having that option you know
even though I'm not I'm not maximizing
and I'm not using it to its fullest
because of all the other things that I
have but just straight off the bat I pay
too much money for entertainment I have
cable I have Netflix Amazon Hulu Disney
Plus Apple TV
I have all of those so and then even
within and I have Hulu that's a Hulu yes
at Hulu so I have all of those right so
the stream wars have started then
they're pulling things you know and I
want to and I want to assess who I think
the winners and losers are in the stream
Wars so to me first of all the winner to
me still the champion is still Netflix
Netflix is still the best and I think
they were ramping themselves up to
prepare for this because you're never
lacking something to watch on Netflix
when you turn that [ __ ] on is like oh
there's a new show you're like oh [ __ ] I
don't even know this person was in a
show or whatever there's always a new
show to watch there's always new movies
to watch there's always documentaries
there's always a whole things that you
love it's always something to watch on
Netflix and it just keeps going and
going and going and going so even if
they're dumb you know what I mean
like Netflix I think some so Netflix I
think is a winner but let's go back now
I think the loser right now in last
place is Apple TV I think Apple TV is
like first of all I don't like the
interface of Apple TV it's hard to
determine like it's not like a regular
streaming service where like everything
you see on the screen you know when
you're looking at your Apple TV or
you're on online or you're on your phone
or on the iPad they're showing you it's
like it's like an app that integrates
all of these other services so like
let's say you there's a show like
whatever show you want to watch it'll
say on the thing Oh watch this on Hulu
or this is on whatever like it's hooked
up to my spectrum so like all of the
apps all the the TV things are there so
like oh this shows on the CW so you
would go boom and it says how do you
watch it and you could pick so it's hard
to determine what are the Apple TV shows
compared to what are the you know the
regular shows on the other streaming
services so I don't really like the
interface I wish it just said like
here's the Apple TV shows and they were
easy to find but they're just not
they're really not easy to find and
there's only like a couple of shows on
Apple TV there's that one that like it's
two woke for me with an Jennifer Aniston
and whatever I don't know what the name
of it is but up here
no one is watching this show but the
critics are trying to jam this [ __ ]
down our throat you know anytime there's
something that's like oh you have to
watch this this is the best show it's
like no one's watching it there has to
be some sort of balance between being
woke and being entertaining and that's a
hard thing to balance and the same thing
happens in comedy in my business I'm
telling you like sometimes you want to
be like super broke and you want to be
like oh I want to be cutting-edge I want
to say something meaningful but that's
not always entertaining and I think some
of these shows that come out there that
they're skirting that line too uh that's
why I like silly [ __ ] but anyway I don't
know if people are watching that show
and that and they're spent so much money
on these shows like Apple TV has two
shows that I watch i watch see and
that's the one with jason mimosa so this
show is like some futuristic like it's
500 years in the future as
post-apocalyptic
like there was some disease that
decimated the human race everybody's
blind so that's the thing though
everybody on the show's blind but
there's like one guy who could see and
then he's like impregnating everybody
and then this it's just like this kind
of like you know you know kind of Lord
of the Flies type of environment pote
like I say post-apocalyptic and and it's
just this adventure I actually enjoyed
it I think it's a beautiful show it's
shot in like the jungle cuz you know
this you know there's five hundred years
from now like if you don't keep up all
the cities and stuff the trees and
everything you're gonna find a way to
live and I'm gonna bust through all the
concrete and boom here we are in a
jungle again so I mean the earth goes on
right so that's basically what the shows
about
you know it's a weird show I gotta be
honest it's weird Jason mimosa's great
you know but he's blind he's a warrior
and he can you know it's just it's so
bizarre like it's such a bizarre show
because your whole time you're thinking
to yourself God how did they do this
being blind like what would I do if I
was blind living in the jungle like just
little things were getting to me like
well what do they do like what are their
[ __ ] rules how do they know where the
bathroom is it's just you know it's just
it makes your whole brain your brain
she kind of glitches cuz you're just
like [ __ ] I just got to suspend my
disbelief with this show and it can be
hard or you just let yourself go and go
wow this is silly fun cuz it's there's
fighting and war and sex and you know
beautiful people in the show so you know
and I think they spent a ton of money on
that show the other show on Apple TV
that I watches this show servant it's an
M night Shyamalan show this is the
creepiest weirdest show I've seen in a
long time I don't know what the [ __ ]
it's about I'm just gonna be honest with
you I can't I don't know what it's I
don't know if there's supernatural
element to it yet I don't know if
there's like if it's just uh you know a
psychological thriller or if there's you
know I don't I don't know yet you know
but basically like it it starts with a
couple and they have a baby and you
think it's a baby but it turns out it's
a doll that this mom who's like had a
psychotic break she thinks this doll is
a real baby then they get a nanny who
comes to take care of the baby right but
this nanny is weird as hell and then all
of a sudden there's a real baby
and then the husband and and the
brother-in-law are sort of in on why the
the the mom why she went crazy so
there's some kind of mysterious death to
the real baby and so now the story goes
along and like all these weird
characters are introduced and you can't
figure out what's going on so I don't
know if this is gonna be one of those em
like Shyamalan at the end of the series
where you're like oh I can't believe
that that happened or I just don't know
but I will say it's very entertaining to
watch but it's also artsy as [ __ ] like a
lot of the camera angles and like that
is a set-piece
a lot of the the the cinematography and
like the choices that they make in that
and like how they shoot scenes I think
is like a character also in the show so
I would recommend you you know sort of
scary psychological thriller type stuff
I would recommend this if you have Apple
TV but again those are the only two that
I actually were interested in and then
the rest of it is kind of like like you
know how you watch Netflix and you look
at all the the options you just kind of
roll past so those are the only two that
I really watch and I don't know if this
is enough entertainment to justify the
cost now I think Apple TV is the
cheapest I believe you could get it for
like $4.99 for a year so I hopefully
they're gonna be adding more stuff but I
don't see it really lasting because I'm
sure there are you losing millions of
dollars because these productions are
expensive so I think Apple TV is in last
place
second to last I hate to say it but it's
Disney plus I think Disney Plus um you
know there was a lot of hype a lot of
you know a lot of fanfare a lot of like
that the Disney name is like a it's a
huge you know it's a huge you know what
I'm actually gonna talk about Disney but
actually I think Amazon comes in after I
think it's Apple TV than Amazon but I'm
still gonna talk about Disney Plus cuz
there is an option to Disney Plus that
I'm gonna get to that it makes it a
little better than Amazon but anyway but
Disney Plus just by itself
no no Disney plus just by itself I think
is in fourth place probably tied with
Amazon but like because Disney Plus like
okay so one you're excited about all
these shows that keep talking about so
maybe when they come out it's gonna be
great but the only show on Disney Plus
worth watching is Mandalorian that's the
one that everybody talks about
everybody's watching if you're a star
Wars fan that is let's say you're not
even a Star Wars fan you know you're
just watching Disney movies all that
stuff's great like having all the old
movies from the archive you know they're
and and some of the old cartoons like
just a Marvel part of it you know the
all the x-men cartoon spider-man
cartoons and then the Disney part you
can watch like you know Beauty and the
Beast and lion king and all those great
they even go back even the old ones are
there but you know but it's not to me
it's not enough new content to make you
go oh this is great
again mandalorian was the only show at
Mendel Oien I really enjoyed but it was
so slow it's a slow show but I really
and it was gripping I enjoyed it I
thought that just having no like having
a guy with a mask on and you like
never cared for people that much that
you really didn't know who they were so
it was great and I liked that they used
a doll instead of like CGI I talked
about this on my podcast with someone
else too because it was like you know it
just it just made it gave it like a it
just gave it like a nostalgic feel to it
right but I but that's still the show
man Louie is over now where the [ __ ] are
all the other shows where's the Hawkeye
show the all the Marvel stuff and then
what's happening with Disney Plus what
I'm finding out now is like they're
taking movies off of it without even
telling us like we don't even know what
happened to those movies like excuse me
home alone and a bunch of those movies
are just like off you know they and then
I noticed like Avengers like they have
the first Avengers then they have
Avengers age of Ultron but infinity Wars
is missing it's not on Disney Plus and
of course they have endgame which is I
became the biggest movie of all time but
like if you're just getting it you're
trying to catch up you just try to be
like oh let me do a little marathon
there's no infinity Wars so I'm like why
is that and they don't explain like
Netflix will be like they'll send you a
little message like here's ten movies
that are coming and here's ten that are
being taken off so you know what's going
on Dizzy's oh excuse me it's more
Disney's all hush-hush so I don't know
what's going on with that I hope they I
hope they explain that I wish they with
you know I really want to know why that
is so that's that part of it and again
like I say they just got this one show
and then again a National Geographic
school thing at this great show this
great stocking docu-series called a
hostile planet it's really fascinating
and so beautifully shot I just you know
you see animals in their environment
it's a hostile environment and how the
animals have to like hunt other animals
and it's they get this fantastic footage
they got this one with this Jaguar like
is in the water and it frickin takes
down an alligator and pulls the
alligator out of the water and it's like
one of these things that imagine if you
would like to crew and you're like oh my
god I can't believe we're capturing this
so that stuff's good but again I don't
think there's enough with Disney Plus
now the only thing that makes Disney
Plus like a step ahead of say Amazon
because I love Amazon too and the thing
about Amazon let's talk about Amazon
real quick
Elmas not so simple like you know they
got a bunch of shows Jack Ryan they got
you know fleabag they got of core from
marvelous mrs. basil and they got a
bunch of little things like that but
what makes Amazon a great it's like you
get it with Amazon Prime so it's like
it's like extra it's not like it's just
that you know what I mean like Disney
Plus should give you other [ __ ] like
it's like if you have Disney Plus you
also get to go to Disneyland for free
then you're like okay well then it
doesn't matter let me just have this are
they give you some other service but
with Amazon you get of course the
delivery you get all that stuff so
having it doesn't hurt you you don't
mean so that's the they don't need to
like spend so much money on all these
ridiculous productions they can pick and
choose what they want and that's what
they do so in terms of entertainment
value I don't think Amazon is that good
you know what I mean but it's still
better than Apple TV I think right
okay so Disney what makes Disney Plus
great is the fact that you have also
Hulu like if you don't have Hulu and
Easley Plus together
also it packages with the ESPN plus it
doesn't make any sense
like just having Disney Plus by itself
don't make any sense to me you it
literally cost you maybe a dollar more
to have Hulu and Disney together now you
combine Hulu with that now you talking
about something that's real cuz Hulu is
great like Hulu I don't even watch mine
if my favorite shows on Hulu I don't
even watch them on cable on my spectrum
app or DVR because you get commercial
free on Hulu so you could pay a little
extra for commercial free on Hulu so I'm
watching all my shows on Hulu you know
they in but they don't have all the
networks I think they don't have CBS
shows on Hulu I don't actually don't
know there's I think it depends on the
studio attached or whatever but like
Hulu is great so if you're talking about
Hulu and Disney Plus as one thing plus
ESPN Plus that makes the whole streaming
service worth it and it's actually the
same amount of money like you get all of
them combined so that kind of makes it
like better you know but like if you
look at these things individually that's
not that good but if you
if you bundle it together I highly
recommend you doing that it's totally
worth bundling so I would bundle it
together and then you get all that then
it kind of makes it like on par with
Netflix sort of but cuz whoo losing out
with a bunch of movies who lose actually
gonna be like the the rated-r Disney
branch you know so if you want to see
like some nasty stuff you would watch
Hulu as opposed to you know Disney plus
so there's that and then you know some
of the shows on Hulu you know I still
like Handmaid's Tale this is a photo
that shows illness even though I think
it's kind of gone off the rails and
because it's not now it's just the
riders coming up with stuff and after a
while you're just kind of like God cuz
something fun happens to these people
like it had to be so grim and dark it's
a really dark show I don't know if it's
the kind of show that should have
continued I think it's the kind of thing
like hey this is what could happen in
the world these how some people think
and then you end it to keep it going
it's kind of like I don't know what's
going on with that but there are some
some good stuff on Hulu you know I went
back to Amazon Amazon had that great
show boys the superhero show that was
really good so like I say there's good
stuff on each of these you just have to
justify why you would pay the money and
like I say Amazon's worth it because all
the other stuff you get Amazon Prime and
all that stuff hulu hulu disney plus
ESPN Plus that makes it worth it but to
me the king is still gonna be netflix it
just is you know even though even though
with Netflix some of these shows that
they put out I just like I just watched
lost in space then this is the remake of
the series that sort of like modern-day
version of it and season one I thought
was cool I like season 1 but this season
2 like they skip [ __ ] like the end of an
episode this the kid is who on a ship
like sort of like on this planet where
he just saved this robot and he's by
himself and then the start of the next
episode
he's rescued like you don't even know
how he was rescued or what happened so I
I don't know I feel like I feel like the
money runs out
on Netflix shows I feel that they start
big they start with a bang and then it's
like boom boom boom boom boom and then
all of a sudden you're like well what
happened with this show why why is it so
you know what why is this why you
skipping skipping steps in the show so
losses space was good
and then I enjoyed The Witcher oh and
Harriet would Harry Caviezel the guy but
Superman The Witcher is based off a book
and then it's what do you call it they
made it into a wit video game but this
is a really fantastic show I love it
it's so bad that it's great you know
it's good and bad at the same time it's
just some sort of like Dungeons &
Dragons type of he's you know uh a hit
man which he's got powers and he's like
hunt he's a monster hunter and it's just
a world of like you know sorcery and
magicians and like a magic school that
people go to and then they get assigned
to like different country different
Kings I don't know it's just it's a fun
show to watch because what I like about
Netflix what I like about online
streaming is they ain't worried about
your your your soft stomach you know if
if they need to show somebody's head
getting cut off the head gonna get cut
off so I like a little I like that sort
of violence and there's like you know
it's sex and violence and magic you're
so if you're a nerd you're getting
everything you you everything you desire
so I think The Witcher is a good show
but again I gotta say I think Netflix is
king you know they got great
documentaries like I just saw that
documentary don't [ __ ] with cats I mean
Dan that [ __ ] was creepy you know just
you got to watch it it's just one of
those shows like if you're an animal
person you're gonna be so disturbed I've
heard a lot of animal people who won't
watch it because they think that they
show these cats getting killed and they
really don't they kind of like let
excuse me let you know that it's
happening but they don't actually show
it so you know a person it's like I'm
not I'm an animal guy but I don't you
know not like that I'm out I was like oh
man are they gonna show this so I'm
watching it's just a bizarre documentary
but again Netflix has got a bunch of
that stuff there's a bunch of great
documentaries on on on Netflix a bunch
of great shows you know they got the
Manhunters show which it's you know
it's hard to know where you stand this
is what I'm saying about being woke so
there's a segment of society that it's
like why are we glorifying serial
killers so if you are in that camp
you're not gonna like this show I don't
think to me I know the nuance and I can
intellectualize that this is just
entertainment and it's just a show
letting you know like oh this happened
and you know less less less that we're
gonna fiction fictionalized some things
but we're gonna show you some stuff that
happened you know you see you're kind of
like all right
I enjoyed it you know but then when you
hear people talk about it you're kind of
like I now I can't enjoy this because of
what you're saying and then there then
you know you know how Hollywood works if
they make one show about serial killers
there's gonna be ten other shows about
serial killers but you know I thought
the one with that what's his name Zac
Efron I thought he was great as what's
the one that everybody always talked
[ __ ] about
I just thought he was great as that
serial killer not Jeffrey Dahmer but one
of those the cute one who cares you guys
I'm sure the chat right now if I'm doing
a live chat of this or being like this
guy that's how much I don't really care
about it you know then they had that oh
that one series unbelievable this one
was about the girl who said someone
raped her and then no one believed her
and then later they realized she was
telling the truth it was really uh it
was a really emotional that was
emotional takes you on an emotional ride
of like what would you do in that
situation if you were those cops like
would you believe her or not I mean it's
like it was it was really well put
together show so that you know like I
said but that's Netflix I think that's
why Netflix is king of the streaming
services right now because they got they
got they got everything you need you
know what I mean like like I said
documentaries all this kind of stuff
they got everything you need so I don't
know I just think that's
I think that's the order so I think I
think Netflix is number one right I
think what would be I don't know he's
nothing and Netflix is number one
there's only there's not a lot a lot of
them right nothing says number one then
I really think that yeah it would be I
guess number two would be like Hulu if
you bundle it number two would be Hulu
Disney plus ESPN plus right then Amazon
then Apple TV so I think Netflix is
still winning the streaming wars now I
hear HBO Max is gonna come out which I
like if you have HBO GO are you not
gonna have HP Oh max I don't know what
the [ __ ] that means
but this is supposedly gonna have like a
bunch of different stuff too like TV
shows and stuff
I heard they took friends off all the
platforms and they're waiting for it to
be on HBO max I also think that on HBO
max The Big Bang Theory is only gonna
stream on HBO max so I don't know what I
don't get what HBO's doing but because
they are to me they already got HBO go
people are already they were they're
originals people already paying for that
so why are you gonna pay for like some
other some other service so I don't know
what the deal is with HBO max but
hopefully that's you know [ __ ] it's
another service we're gonna have to pay
for right but then this year's wife
thing's gonna hit up happening to I
think a company like Amazon is going to
they're gonna like they're gonna be like
are you tired of paying for all the
streaming services separately we've
bundled them all here pay this amount
and you know that's gonna be [ __ ]
cable that's what cable was so it's good
we gonna end up going full circle or
being back to like where you have a
bundle of like you know hulu netflix
amazon disney plus cuz to me they're all
networks at this point now netflix
started is like you know like a
blockbuster and they turned into a
freakin full-on entertainment company so
you know they're no different than HBO
showtime or anything like that so i
don't know then i don't even count those
like
anytime they would really be in last
place like no one I know is paying for
Showtime anytime like if you're not
getting Showtime as some kind of bundle
why would you get it you know then
they're charging like I just this is the
reason why I'm dying up here was
cancelled I don't just just not enough
people have access to Showtime so I
don't know about it again that's the
worst in the streaming wars then I mean
there's other ones too like epics and I
think if you think about all those
stations that you have to like pay extra
for even on cable you know it's like
who's paying for that you know I I pay
for cable and I still I'm like very
limited I'm really trying to figure out
which where do I want to pay for it
like I love HBO so do I get HBO with you
know on Hulu actually which actually
makes you know you could get but Amazon
does the same thing so so Amazon you had
the option to pay to buy HBO Showtime
and those kind of stations Hulu does the
same thing Hulu has the you know
different stations you know so I want to
know somebody send me a message about
like if whoever has Hulu TV because I
noticed that too you can like get like
live TV on Hulu I haven't tried that one
of my friends is using YouTube's TV so
they again those are all different
options too so I don't know I don't know
which one is the better to me it just
seems like you end up paying the same
amount of money you were paying for
cable like people are like all more get
rid of cable because it's too expensive
but then they paying $50 for the
Internet 15 for HBO 15 for this one 15
for that one when it's all Senator and
then if you get like the $50 for like
the YouTube TV or TV you're talking
about you spending like cable money you
you spend a cable money for frickin the
same thing anyway so [ __ ] I don't know
all right I saw Star Wars the most
recent Star Wars and I'm like I said I'm
probably gonna have one of the both Lee
brothers on I don't know if we can have
them all together but I have one of them
on both of them are gonna come on I just
it's hard to wrangle these guys so in
the meantime I thought I'd talk about it
myself I don't know if you if you're not
a star with
person I guess you could check out now
but like I actually I actually enjoy
this most recent Star Wars what's it
called um something's something
Skywalker you know I don't know what I
don't know what to name it but what is
the name of this one let me look this
[ __ ] up recent Star Wars recent Star
Wars movies oh yeah the rise of
Skywalker yeah um I didn't hate it
actually I didn't hate it like I hated
the last Jedi that one was terrible but
this one I you know it was okay I
thought the special effects were great
but I feel like they're making [ __ ] up
as they go like one of the things I just
do not like you know I don't want to
talk about this toons laughs I get it
doesn't matter if I talk about it again
another time who cares right but like
they just making up Jedi powers like
we've been in this Star Wars universe
for 40 years right and all of a sudden
now Jedi's can like teleport [ __ ] you
know like I wish they were that it's
like you can't just add a new power out
of nowhere so I don't know but I feel
like they're just trying to make sense
of everything but like in the last Jedi
so in the last Jedi remember Luke is
like transmitting himself with the force
he's still on the island but he's making
people believe he's there so he has a
necklace that he gives to Leia he's like
oh that's our necklace it's some kind of
family heirloom but when he vanishes the
necklace vanishes but in rise of
Skywalker apparently he could have just
brought that necklace and gave it to her
through the Jedi power why didn't he do
that you know I just I I don't I don't
understand you know and then they then
it's like again even though I don't
agree with the premise that she's now
spoiler alert everybody spoiler alert
that Emperor / Emperor Palpatine the
Emperor is actually her grandfather
something they were trying to parallel
the
a movie like you know how Darth Vader
was Luke's father now this is you know I
didn't agree with that freaking
storyline that premise of that storyline
but I like how it was executed in the
movie you know I thought that it was you
know again I thought it was it nicely
shot movie was beautiful the special
effects were great the story was I gave
it like a b-plus you know I didn't hate
it and I will see I even like teared up
a couple times when I was watching uh at
the end I thought I was like why am i
crying and his [ __ ] with me but like
it was a couple of like really like good
moments in the movie so and I was in
Washington DC and I was my cousin Alyssa
was with we she didn't want to go see it
but I took her in afterwards she was
like it was dope it was Adele that's not
my cousin it so she she enjoyed it and
she didn't even know any other movies so
I mean as a standalone movie I thought
it was like you know it was interesting
again the special effects stuff but I
just in terms of like in the Star Wars
universe I just feel like these are like
like as if they read as if they're like
remakes of the Star Wars universe I
didn't like that all of a sudden Leia is
like all of a sudden this Jedi Master
but I wouldn't [ __ ] did that happen so
they sort of made reference to it like
oh she was training when she was younger
but then in him they didn't make
reference to it in any of the other
movies so it was kind of like well what
happened here so I feel like the people
were like they sat down and they were
like yo I think we ruined this whole
franchise let's see we can get it back
on on track but I don't know if they did
or not I think the other movies were so
bad that this one just being a little
bit better made it worth it and good but
I don't know it's hard to tell you know
it's like I don't know I can't I can't
figure out what my favorite I know that
none of these new Star Wars are even
close to being my favorite movie of the
Star Wars series it's always gonna go
back to the originals you know young
people they look at those and they're
like those are so old they look terrible
but whatever I just think this those
were just better stories I thought the
the inner
but the actors were better I thought
just I don't know I just I just feel
like Star Wars Empire and Return of the
Jedi are still the gold standard for the
Star Wars universe and these movies are
just like okay you know I thought those
three that came that they're original
not the original tree with the next
three that George Lucas did those were
all terrible with the young Anakin and
you know Hayden Christensen and they
those movies were just they just were
not very good okay they just weren't
very good so you kind of like on the
Star Wars universe after that and then
they just kept going with these three
that it's like what's going on here with
that yeah but the casino one was
terrible and then this the one after
that uh I I don't know I just I don't
understand Ray's story so they tried to
put it together you know they tried to
like oh here's what it is
you know Palpatine's son obviously had
her and I don't know it didn't make any
sense to me you know it just really did
it and so what if I think about in the
totality of the holy Star Wars universe
I actually think it's a show Mandalorian
I think that show is better than a lot
of the movies I thought rogue one was
good but like so I'm looking forward to
what's happening in in rogue one I mean
I'm sorry
in Mandalorian I want to see where
that's going you know cuz apparently
they're gonna talk about Jedi's and all
this kind of stuff it's just but just to
get but just come and go back to
Mandalorian I guess we can cuz I'm gonna
have to ask I'm [ __ ] running the show
this is my thing I feel like this is my
ramble on podcast but I don't care I
love doing solo episodes so the thing
about Mandalorians I love baby Yoda but
baby Yoda is 50 years old okay so like
remember original Yoda is like eight
hundred years old so baby Yoda is 50
years old and this is supposedly four
years after Return of the Jedi I think I
can't figure out where Mandalorian is in
the timeline I'm not sure if like the
people that made Mandalorian are trying
to wipe out all of the Rays stuff you
know maybe that's maybe that's later I
can't figure out where they are in the
universe I need somebody to help explain
that to me but
if baby Yoda is 50 years old that means
he was alive that little baby if it's a
girl I don't know was a girl right it
was alive through all of Star Wars and
all that stuff so maybe whatever whoever
is supposed to what do you call it bring
balance to the force
maybe it was never the Skywalker's maybe
it was bait this baby Yoda is actually
the one that's gonna balance to the
force
who knows or is this like a race of
people of beings that all have
tremendous Jedi power you know what I
mean I mean just think about how Luke in
the original series how long it took him
to like get his powers in order like he
had to be upside down you don't mean but
then again just [ __ ] baby Yoda is 50
years old so we didn't even see when he
was only like you know 25 maybe he
couldn't do the Yoda powers that he has
now I mean 50 is like you've lived a
long time and say maybe you've time to
develop your powers but he's still a
baby at the same time he's still like he
you don't talk you know he acts like a
baby you know I mean like baby Yoda
reminds me a Stewie from from Family Guy
like around certain people it's a baby
but then other times it can make you
know a time machine you know I would
love to see a battle between Stewie and
baby Yoda so I don't know I just think
like I want to see where the mandalorian
goes I think that's a great I really
like what they're starting with that but
again hey Disney Plus like only eight
episodes and then you don't have
anything else following up you know and
speaking of what I like about
Mandalorian and we can thank the MCU the
Marvel Universe for this it's because of
Marvel that even Disney's figured out oh
that's not let's not leave the universe
let's just make movies within the
universe they're just making terrible
movies like solo no one even talks about
that one anymore like sold that's that
solo solo movie who you know with uh
with uh once I forgot the guy's name the
guy that looks older than then Han Solo
did you know he's supposed to be young
Han Solo but he looked older than Han
Solo looks
the original Star Wars I don't know I
just you know so you if you're not gonna
make great movies these branch-off
movies if they're not gonna be great
you're gonna you gonna turn us off man
this is why DC is failing like the DC
Universe is so terrible it's like no one
cares they can't keep a Batman now they
lost Superman so in our minds you're
kinda like okay well what's going on I
can't connect the way I was able to
connect with Marvel even if the movies
were bad like Captain America the
original one terrible first Thor
terrible second Thor terrible like
somebody's movies were just not good The
Hulk was terrible that's the one carried
a switch didn't keep at Norton they got
what's-his-name so you know but like if
somebody's movies just were not good but
the universe was connected so we were
like I let's see where this is gonna go
DC they just can't get their [ __ ] right
man they can't I'm interested I'm
looking forward to seeing this Wonder
Woman 84 1984 Wonder Woman but you know
even that one I don't know like how's
that guy alive like I saw Wonder Woman
he went in the plane the [ __ ] plane
exploded how is he alive please explain
to me how he's alive like I'm already
I'm already out because I started Kris
pines character I was like how is he
alive
well they explained this to me so I
don't know we'll see how that one comes
about but so anyways to bring it back is
like getting to Marvel people they did
that right so Star Wars is trying to do
it like that but I don't know like were
they gonna go next is this the end of
they said it was the end of Skywalker
but then at the end of the movie one of
the guys like what's your name and she's
all you know the last my um you know ray
Skywalker and say [ __ ] no you're not
you Palpatine just be who you are I
don't get that you know when she kissed
uh what's his name um what's his name um
the bad guy who you know who went good
you know all of a sudden you know I wish
I was like oh that'd be a good their
baby would be like super powerful
Skywalker Papa team together like damn
but you know he disappears so he's gone
he vanishes in the force you know in the
dark side and you know I don't know I
sometimes I don't get to force the dark
side you know light side I don't get I
don't get that like why would you choose
the dark side and then call it the dark
side you know what I mean it's like it's
like if you said hey join the evil side
you you wouldn't say it like that
because how would you how would you
justify in your head that you're on the
wrong side you're saying you're evil it
shouldn't be dark side I never liked
that it shouldn't have been like you
know the light and the dark because dark
implies something bad but they don't
believe that they're bad right I mean do
they think they're bad or do they don't
they think that they're justified in how
they act so it I don't look now we're
going down a psychological you know
discussion about is the dark side good
or bad or whatever that is then that'll
be fir I guess another episode I don't
know but guys I want to thank you for
listening to me ramble on refer at
Griffin you know to recap again Pope
crazy think he's on his way out
Gabrielle Union stop [ __ ] shaming people
streaming wars streaming wars
um I think Netflix is still king that's
just my opinion if you disagree with me
you know please write in the comments
what you think but I don't think that
these other ones are can compare they
can't compete with Netflix even though I
just read a story that they thought
Apple was gonna buy Netflix isn't that
crazy
the Apple got that kind of money there's
something like a hundred and eighty nine
billion dollars to buy Netflix I was
like damn that's who owns Netflix is
there like did anybody know is there
like a sole owner of Netflix or just
some kind of conglomerate of like
shareholders I don't know but damn 189
billion dollars for something [ __ ] so
anyways the streaming wars Mandalorians
great Star Wars movie was like I give it
a B+ you could do worse you know you
could do worse and oh that's a Gabby
Gabby interception shame it and what's
the
and please please subscribe to riffing
with Griffin I'm actually you know I'm
really enjoying doing this so please
subscribe and also if you want to watch
me game I'm still man I'm still playing
call of duty I have not won a solo
victory I'm playing blackout the Battle
Royale
I was playing on my channel on this
channel for a little while
but then I was told that you know it's
not good to mix like that so I made a
new channel so if you want to watch me
game please subscribe to that channel
it's youtube.com slash Erik Griffin
gaming so please subscribe to that
channel if you want to watch me game
because I have some other gaming videos
and I still haven't won a Call of Duty
blackout it's the battle royale you know
it starts with a hundred people you have
to find weapons and then and then light
the Matt keeps shrinking and then you
have to like you know be the last one
standing the best I've done is fourth
place and I've tried like oh my god I've
played like 300 matches well when I keep
that victory it's gonna be like yes you
know so so please if you want to
subscribe to that channel please
subscribe to that Channel and once again
please go to Eric Griffin comm excuse me
please go to Eric Griffin comm for my
show dates I'm coming all over the place
this year I'm gonna Cleveland I'm going
to like this Hamilton Hamilton isn't
like in Canada near Toronto I'm going to
a lot of different places it'll be on my
website and get updated by the time this
comes out and you know keep on doing
what you do guys keep helping me push me
push me to like make it show better I
appreciate you listening I appreciate I
appreciate you watching and I'll see you
next week
[Music]